les filles votre mère et moi allons
divorcer la monogamie n'est pas réaliste la
monogamie n'est pas réaliste
ou la monogamie allemande n'est pas réaliste je
ne comprenais pas ce mot à l'époque
mais maintenant je sais exactement de quoi il
parlait samedi j'adorerais ça
si tu étais mon rendez-vous, je ne peux pas faire ça
parce que comme toi et moi nous nous reverrons jamais me
réveiller chaque matin de l'argent
juste coolin je poursuis toute la matinée
dans un sous-sol d'église et un chien
ça va menacer juste parce que tu ne
comprends pas le concept du mariage tu l'
habilles comme ça pour que personne d'autre ne
veuille coucher avec lui c'est cool
je suis juste une nana moderne qui fait ce
qu'elle veut la semaine dernière  c'était ce gars de la
tyrolienne dans la boîte
hé Mark Wahlberg tais-toi Mark Wahlberg
Mark Wahlberg est comme 150 livres je ressemble
à Mark Wahlberg a mangé Mark Wahlberg
avant de juger tu devrais savoir que je
vais bien mes amis sont géniaux mes
appartements sont malades et j'ai un  super j  ob
dans un magazine pour hommes
j'aimerais Amy tu es intelligente mais tu n'es
pas trop intelligente tu es jolie et
tu n'es pas magnifique tu es accessible
merci ouais je te donne une
mission
j'ai besoin d'un profil  sur un médecin du sport donc
tu fais l'article sur moi mm-hmm
désolé d'affilée on regarde Downton Abbey
plus tard LeBron je suis interviewé
écoute je le regarde ce soir donc je
ne vais pas aller m'entraîner et tout le
les gars en parlent et je suis laissé de
côté tous les sports immondes je les
aime qui est ton équipe préférée les
luhan d'Orlando est-ce que je prends un verre
ouais qu'est-ce que je fais j'ai dormi chez le
médecin la nuit dernière non garçon
j'intime oui sexuel  rapports sexuels oh tu
ne passes jamais la nuit
qu'est-ce que tu étais ivre pas comme deux
verres trois max quatre maintenant que je compte parce que
tu es un fou de X ou
quelque chose il m'appelle pourquoi
vous appellerait-il les gars juste une seconde c'est Amy  Je
pense que tu m'as appelé non je t'ai appelé
avec mes doigts as-tu dit
clé sympa raccroche il est  évidemment comme des
autocollants je nous appelais ils ont passé un
très bon moment la nuit dernière je me demande si
tu le veux euh je vais appeler la
police